we welcome you back to CBS mornings
we've got new reporting in our
investigation of veterans who were
discharged because of their sexuality
and are struggling to clear their
records from World War II into the
repeal of don't ask don't tell back in
2010 an estimated 100
000 lgbtq plus service members were
kicked out of the military while many
walked away with less than honorable
discharges some faced even harsher
consequences Chief investigative
correspondent that would be Jim auxelrod
joins us at the table with more on this
story these stories are hard to believe
to me good morning to see you Jim this
one's going to get even harder good
morning
we've been profiling veterans still
paying the price for a policy that is no
longer the law of the land denied
certain benefits unable to pursue
certain jobs but few have paid a more
severe price than the vet you're about
to meet the military didn't just boot
him for being gay the military put him
in prison
[Music]
at Seattle First Baptist Church where
the Seattle Men's Chorus is rehearsing
for its Pride concert
perhaps the only thing matching the
power of the singing voices the story
shared with the spoken ones as my sexual
identity blossomed I battled with how to
live the covert double life that was
required of lgbtq military members at
that time like the story of Steve morose
and his time as an Air Force officer in
the late 1980s when gay men and women
could not serve openly it all came
crashing down in 1990 when an
investigation into an enlisted friend
led to my being court-martialed for a
conduct on becoming an officer the the
son of an Air Force Master Sergeant
morose had an excellent record until the
Air Force discovered he was gay and
charged him with three counts of
consensual sodomy and two for conduct on
becoming an officer you were looking at
17 years in prison I was five years per
sodomy charge and a year per contact I'm
incoming charge for living your Truth
for being me
it wasn't uncommon then for gay service
members to be court-martialed and thrown
out of the military so morose pleaded
guilty but the judge had other ideas so
when he came back in and sat down and
said his decision was 24 months of
confinement my heart sank because again
I thought my military life was over but
in that moment I thought my life was
over and was sentenced to two years at
Fort Leavenworth can you describe
Leavenworth to me I mean I did get to
know people that were there for Life who
for rape for murder was it a tough place
was the military justice system used to
punish gay and lesbian members of the
military for their sexuality a hundred
percent retired lieutenant colonel
Rachel van landingham is a law professor
who served 24 years in the Air Force is
Steve morossa's case unique there are
thousands that have been incarcerated
for their sexuality a six-month CBS News
investigation found the military used a
range of cover charges to Target gay and
lesbian service members for their
sexuality before and even during don't
ask don't tell
article 125 directly criminalized
unnatural copulation but other statutes
included conduct Unbecoming indecent
acts and making false official
statements the numbers are very
difficult to actually ascertain because
there are so many alternative ways to
involuntarily separate an individual
from the military without putting on
paper that you were doing so because of
their sexual orientation does the United
States military know just how many
people have been imprisoned for their
sexuality no because they don't want to
know but could they figure this out yes
if they cared enough they could go
through the records
foreign
decades after his release from Fort
Leavenworth Steve morose is still paying
the price that wasn't able to become a
police dispatcher why couldn't you be a
police dispatcher because I have a
record because I have an FBI file
because you're a felon correct
have you ever thought I want my record
cleared I want my discharge upgraded I
want access to my benefits I have and I
didn't pursue it partly
because I had heard how hard it was how
difficult is it for someone like Steve
to have his conviction overturned it's
way more difficult than it should be it
should be incredibly easy but morose and
an Untold number of other veterans are
still waiting for the Pentagon to make
things right they have the ability to do
a retroactive look and say people who
are hanging under the weight of
something that is no longer valid
should be made whole what could be
bigger than restoring
someone's Humanity a sense of justice to
somebody's life especially if that
you're that person nothing
foreign
statement to CBS News the defense
department spokesperson said as they
always do it would be inappropriate to
comment on a specific case adding the
department cannot legally quote set
aside a conviction once appellate review
is complete the spokesperson also
encouraged veterans who believe they
were wrongfully discharged to reach out
to the applicable review board to
determine their eligibility for Relief
that I will tell you what the Pentagon
continues to do is decline our request
to sit down and answer some questions
about what is a fundamentally broken
process but I like how you phrase it as
they always do we cannot comment at this
time but if the Pentagon can't do
anything to overturn this who can well
we asked Rachel van landingham that
question the expert we just heard from
and because what Steve morose and other
veterans have been told to seek a
presidential pardon and Van laningham
just left said they ought to they ought
to buy some lottery tickets while
they're at it they got a better chance
of winning the lottery than getting a
presidency and then of course the
question is is it lingering homophobia
or is it just bureaucratic well you know
what's never been done there's never
been a formal apology issued not to this
point so we could start there so it's
like a great start so is the military
doing anything to address this now I
wish I knew I wish I could tell you but
that would require them answering some
questions well Jim I'll tell you what um
doing stories like this will help apply
pressure in areas that need it
appreciate you